yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah after I did not upload the video
before I simply couldn't I am I play
them my opponent played into he just
made a mistake into a losing ending and
instead of playing in the move I mean I
saw them look that that did it it was
easy and I made a mullet was what I'm
trying to say instead of just winning I
mouse lived into a lost ending and yeah
then I was curling so hard I needed to
stop this i could not release that video
I'm sorry about it I'm still kind of
just hate that and roll the dead ending
and he blundered just like completely I
didn't understand it there and and then
Mouse look great this is really am those
are the moments where you really want to
write bite into your desk em ok so um
here we've got a abencoe and a pretty
good one for black I believe why it is
not sure why this doing with it doesn't
look very threatening here I've got the
beef farm and no particular problems
Queen to be five maybe next lamp like
it's very ok no reason to believe that
there are any problems
okay so he tries to trade everything
down that that might work that might
work so rock chicks one you will take a
seven it is slightly more comfortable
for black this position but it's not
nothing special just because of the
magic to the team but ok cannot go
Bishop before here because of 92
definitely more active and f5 is an
important resource so we are night see
to night siege we will have to go into a
bad structure I can take their only
three now so take only 3 and then what
[Music]
once i have ok for you all right pietas
on the knowing side Jim I'll take this
and now have a look I think think this
is good just attack III thing is that um
the e4 part is also week so if i go here
[Music]
94 i continue three this is a pretty
good rogue ending 5 takes that can take
and go be4 should also win a pawn it's a
bit awkward yeah this one I did not
really have on the radar it's okay
probably okay let's do this first fix
all the weaknesses and go from there
[Music]
yeah f5 is something that I could try
[Music]
probably have to maybe I should've done
that earlier with a cable theme my idea
is to isolate the d5 pawn it's not easy
to win it though I mean look fi ok can
play group d 3 so what's what's going on
can any way to make some progress in
this position ok 294 doesn't look like
much oopsie to know
anything I can do with the bishop I know
I know I don't think LH six is doing
much yeah I think he tries to open up
the e4 square for the night
lets going back okay check
[Music]
maybe just go before here or no this one
[Music]
so time were naked and then 94
yeah ninety-four just work hmm cannot do
much about that
check
30 seconds
[Music]
it's just a very dry
check check check check I don't know can
get bone any could be a bit tricky check
check check check game drawn yeah sure
didn't make much out of this certainly
was quite good i don't think i have 0 ba
gia that's much better yeah I saw that
this is also better for black hood it
might not be enough what what what the
thing is I immediately a5 is strong okay
yeah more or less winds upon in the
center I mean I was just too tempted by
the bad structure may be young but maybe
he just defends that it's all on one
it's all on one one side of the board
and sometimes you cannot do much against
that I think this is one of those kids
it looks nice I had to play against the
structure of it it might just be
adjusted or so instead f5 is doing the
trick yeah its pieces are pretty badly
placed to encounter f5 as 45 have no
support at all something like that just
this is just dropping the pawn right now
this is what the engine gives it's also
pretty awful yeah so that was the
opportunity and the way to use this this
is this good opening position Mikey
everything was very nice ok guys thanks
for watching